herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute viele von euch haben sich
gewünscht hat sich mal wieder in ried
talk video macht also ein video in dem
ich mal wieder ernst über ein thema
machen jetzt ist die gelegenheit
gekommen
denn es gibt nämlich eine sache die
vielen von euch wenn nicht sogar allen
schon begegnet ist aber die man
eigentlich gar nicht spricht über die es
aber sehr wichtig ist zu sprechen
deswegen werden wir darüber und zwar
heißt das team aber dass leute reden
achtung fremd vor populismus leute
populismus ein paar von euch haben das
wort vielleicht schon gehört ein paar
von euch bestimmt noch nicht mal gemein
erst mal solche die menschen die
populismus betreiben nennt man
populisten das ist quasi die die das
macht das populärste den themen gehen
erstmal darüber so populisten im
allgemeinen machen das ganze ist ein
thema aus der politik und populisten
versuchen indem sie übertreiben und die
aktuelle lage als viel viel viel
dramatischer und schlimmer und
schlechter als sie eigentlich ist
darzustellen die gunst von leuten zu
gewinnen und dann ihm auch sagen leute
okay die lage ist so und so wir haben
eine ganz einfache lösung dafür und die
sieht so aus liebe war ein ganz
einfaches youtube beispiel ist okay das
ist jetzt wirklich gut aus aber ich bin
heute aber schon mal vor in deutschland
gibt's youtuber die click welt betreibt
und von diesen youtube-clip mehr
betreiben haben rein zufällig zwei
schwarzen locken detail von den haben
einfach schwarze locken und was daneben
so genannte populisten machen würden ist
ganz einfach zu sagen pflegte zerstört
ganz youtube ist sicherlich für youtube
ist zerstört ganz deutschland und schuld
daran sind youtuber mit schwarzen haaren
die lösung dafür ist einfach youtube mit
schwarzen haaren von youtube haben alle
das prinzip ist im allgemeinen übernimmt
wird ein problem
übertreibt es dann richtig krass und
bietet dann eine viel zu einfache lösung
dafür an das war jetzt natürlich relativ
einfach ist und hält du musst beispiel
aber im echten leben kann die ganze
sache relativ ernst werden wenn es zum
beispiel darum geht dass auf einmal alle
muslime raus aus deutschland zahlen wenn
es darum geht dass alle menschen die in
der bank arbeiten verbrecher sind diese
so genannte populisten spielen also mit
den echten
ängsten von leuten und nutzen die aus
indem sie ganz krass übertreiben was
natürlich zu noch mehr angst führt und
dann sagen aber davon will sie ganz
tolle lösung kommt doch zu uns leute wir
können euch sagen liebe dieses problem
lösen können und so eine übermäßige
vereinfachung führt eben ganz schnell
dazu dass man gewisse menschen ausgrenzt
bezogen auf die beispiele die ich gerade
eben gegeben habe werde zum beispiel die
ausgrenzung von muslimen oder die
ausgrenzung von menschen die banken
arbeiten sieht das ganze thema zeichnet
sich auch dadurch aus dass man sich von
den fakten und von der echten realität
verabschiedet geben in dem man so krass
zu übertreiben dem man die aktuelle lage
als deutlich dramatischer darstellen als
sie eigentlich ist entfernt man sich
natürlich auch im gleichen moment von
der welt wie die welt eben eigentlich
ist man scheint also wenn man das so
sagen möchte ganz bewusst auf die
realität und sagt okay wir übertreiben
das jetzt mal richtig krass wenn dann
würdest du würdest du und das ist ein
riesengroßes problem weil es beim
menschen dazu führen kann dass sie sich
denken ohrwürmer die ganze welt ist doch
eigentlich scheiße von der gruppe von
personen sind alle kriminelle von der
gruppe von personen stehen alle und die
gruppe von personen ist eigentlich
komplett dummen das führt natürlich zu
hören und im endeffekt okay die welt ist
eigentlich komplett
jetzt brauchen wir irgend jemanden der
uns daraus wird und das sind dann eben
diese populisten zwar probleme also
leute sind vielleicht ängstlicher und
hingeht schlechter als es ihnen
eigentlich gehen müsste und zweitens
diese leute werde die hände von menschen
betrieben eben in die hände von diesem
populisten die eigentlich selbst gar
keine richtige lösung für das problem
haben von denen sie alle waren und die
große feier ist natürlich was kann man
dagegen machen er gibt es einen roadtrip
und zwar habe ich ja schon gesagt dass
die populisten sich gerne mal ein
bisschen von der realität oder von den
fakten die wir jetzt eigentlich gerade
aussieht entfernt wenn man also wirklich
wissen will was eigentlich gerade abgeht
und ob man vor allem banker angst haben
muss weil sie einen abzocken kann da
gibt es eine möglichkeit und zwar man
schaut sich mal die realität an shops
mal die fakten an das machen wird anhand
von zwei themen die wir seit 4
sollte eine sache die ihr vielleicht
auch schon gehört hat ist flüchtlinge
nehmen deutschen die arbeitsplätze weg
wenn dieser satz zustimmen will könnte
man sich natürlich zu recht krass
aufregen weil wenn das so war ist wenn
es natürlich ziemlich scheiße für alle
die jetzt schon ihren deutschland sind
schauen wir mal die fakten als manche
leute haben gedacht dass eine große
anzahl an flüchtlingen die nach
deutschland kommt ein problem lösen
könnte dass die deutsche wirtschaft hat
und zwar dass dadurch das
folgerung immer älter wird es immer
weniger fachkräfte also immer weniger
gut ausgebildete leute jetzt ist
allerdings so dass viele von den
geflüchteten oder flüchtling nach
deutschland gekommen sind gar nicht so
gut ausgebildet sind die meisten sind
das vorgestellt haben und ohne gute
ausbildung ist dass ich auch relativ
schweren job wegzunehmen wenn man das
ganze jetzt wohl ironisch ausdrücken
möchte heißt das es ist schwieriger als
gedacht diese flüchtlinge in den
arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren dazu habe
ich mal ein paar zahlen raus zu von den
2013 nach deutschland zugezogen
flüchtlingen haben heute 31 ein job von
den 2014 zugezogenen 22 prozent von den
2015 zugezogenen heute nur 10
ein job das heißt also ein ganz großer
teil hat immer noch keinen job das
problem dabei ist dass viele eine gute
schul- oder berufsausbildung haben und
sicherlich auch einige eben nicht so gut
deutsch können und das ganze macht
natürlich schwierig die einzustellen und
von denjenigen die tatsächlich an
eingestellt werden arbeiten jahre
meistern hilfsjobs und die allermeisten
sogar in phase jetzt irgend ein großer
zauberer mit dem finger schnipsen würde
und alle geflüchteten nach deutschland
gekommen auf einmal perfekt ausbilden
könnte würden diese natürlich mit den
menschen die bereits in deutschland sind
auch um arbeitsplätze konkurrieren das
heißt dann wollte vielleicht zwei den
gleichen arbeitsplatz aber der anteil
der geflüchteten an der deutschen
bevölkerung macht gerade ungefähr ein
prozent aus also ein hundertstel das
heißt da ist die auswirkungen die die
gruppe haben kann vielleicht auch gar
nicht so jemand auch für zweite aussage
ein und zwar auf die schere zwischen arm
und reich und zwischen menschen denen
geld nächste ich gut geht und den ins
game nicht schlecht geht immer weiter
auseinander
da ist jetzt schon mehr daran denn in
entwickelten ländern das heißt soll ich
mir in deutschland oder den vereinigen
staaten oder in frankreich wachsen die
sogenannten sozialen ungleichheiten das
heißt die sozial auch finanziell
unterschied zwischen menschen aus
verschiedenen schichten wie man so
nennen möchte dazu kommt dass immer mehr
menschen als arm gelten in deutschland
gibt es mehr als einzelne person also
ich persönlich will ich jetzt alleine in
einer wohnung liebe und ich weniger als
900 euro pro monat habt dann gelte ich
als arten zu dieser gruppe der armen
gehören neben mir mehr menschen in
deutschland jetzt natürlich die frage
wie geht das weiter haben wir bald nur
noch milliardäre und leute die für einen
euro am tag arbeiten in deutschland
würden da gibt es unter experten zum
beispiel wissenschaftlern
unterschiedlicher meinen einige sagen
nämlich dass menschen die behaupten dass
es bald nur noch superreiche und
bettelarme in deutschland gibt eben
populisten sind man muss also immer ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein
heute eine besonders einfache lösung
anbieten wollen es gibt ein paar dinge
leute die brauchen wir alle im leben und
eine sache davon dass eben zb genug geld
um sich klamotten kaufen zu können um
sich essen kaufen zu können um die
eigene miete zu zahlen und deswegen
haben menschen angst davor irgendwann
kein geld mehr zu haben weil sie ihren
job verlieren weil irgendjemand in ihren
job wegnimmt zum beispiel oder eben weil
manche leute erzählen hinzu es gibt halt
nur noch mehr wäre in deutschland werden
alle anderen unterjochung und versklaven
und bei eben diesen ganz normal und ganz
natürlichen ängsten eigentlich auch
setzen populisten an übertreiben
probleme die ist zwar tatsächlich gibt
eine ganz andere größenordnung und sagen
dann eben okay wir haben die lösung
dafür kommt zu uns und das kann
lebensgefährlich sein deswegen zwar
leute lasst euch keine holzmachen schaut
euch immer eines tages war die fakten an
wenn ihr vor irgendwas richtig angst hat
schaut einfach mal drauf wie die
wirklichkeit eigentlich da aussieht und
ob das was irgendwann euch erzählt ja
ich kann irgendwas angst machen will
auch so wirklich war es der zyniker ich
hoffe ein paar von euch ein bisschen was
von dem thema mitgenommen also danke
dass du schon wie immer
denkt nach benutzt den kopf